So the grift in the corruption, you're both
coming full circle.
Rudy Giuliani has reportedly discussed a blanket
preemptive pardon from President Donald Trump
in these last seven weeks before Trump leaves
office.
Trump also reportedly considering preemptive
blanket pardons for three of his children,
as well as his son in law, Jared Kushner.
The New York Times can report, based on multiple
sources told about the conversation, that
Rudy Giuliani as recently as last week was
talking to Donald Trump about a pardon.
It's not clear as of yet whether Rudy Giuliani
originally brought it up to Trump or whether
Trump brought it up to Giuliani.
But there have now reportedly been multiple
conversations.
The most recent one was last week.
Donald Trump has reportedly not yet decided
what he will do about pardoning Rudy Giuliani.
And the same questions remain about Trump
pardoning Jared Kushner as well as his children,
Ivanka Don Jr. and Eric.
Now, Trump reportedly not considering a pardon
for Tiffany Trump.
I guess he doesn't expect that she might be
charged with anything.
But the immediate question is pardon?
From what?
Rudy hasn't even been charged with anything.
Neither have his children.
And that is exactly the question that's raising
the most attention.
It's not actually clear what Rudy Giuliani
might be charged with in the future, but the
fact that it's being discussed multiple times
at the highest levels is very interesting.
We know that Rudy was being investigated last
summer by federal investigators for maybe
violating lobbying law through the work he
did with Ukraine.
But beyond that, it's not exactly clear.
Now, what we do know is that as a general
concept, the idea here is that with regard
to his children and son in law, at least,
and it may be similar with Rudy Giuliani,
Donald Trump believes that there will be partizan
investigations and possibly prosecutions of
his children after he leaves office.
And so it's not because from Trump's perspective,
it's not that he thinks his kids committed
crimes.
It's that he thinks they didn't.
But they might be charged with crimes anyway.
Bipartisan partizan Joe Biden administration.
What?
You know, there's this funny thing.
Trump always projects his immorality and his
do whatever for a buck or whatever for revenge
sort of attitude on other people.
Trump is worried Biden would go after Trump's
kids even though they didn't do anything as
far as Trump is concerned, because that's
exactly what Trump would do if he were Joe
Biden.
But Joe Biden has clearly shown no interest
and has even said he has no plan to direct
his Justice Department to do anything of the
sort.
But a lot of Trump's behavior is motivated
by what Trump imagines he would do if in someone
else's position.
Now, Rudy Giuliani's spokeswoman was asked
about the seeking a pardon and she said Giuliani
can't comment on any discussions he's had
with his client, Trump being his client.
So what we're talking about here are blanket,
broad, open ended preemptive pardons.
This is very rare, but it has happened in
the past.
George Washington.
Yeah, we have to go, but we don't have to
go back that far.
But one notable example goes back to George
Washington who pardoned those who were plotting
the Whiskey Rebellion so that they wouldn't
be prosecuted for treason.
Gerald Ford pardoned Richard Nixon for all
his actions as president.
Now, it is important to remember a few important
things about presidential pardons.
Number one, they work for federal crimes,
not state crimes.
So if the Southern District of New York, as
an example, were to bring charges against
Rudy or Ivonka or whoever, we're still not
sure for what.
But if they did, the pardon from Trump wouldn't
protect them there.
Number two, whether preemptive blanket pardons
work is a legal question.
And what I mean by that is a president can
do it.
And in the past, these preemptive pardons
have dissuaded anybody from prosecuting the
pardoned individuals.
Like, for example, when Gerald Ford pardoned
Richard Nixon, the pardon was challenged legally.
It was found to be constitutional, but it
was never brought to the Supreme Court.
It is conceivable that a Supreme Court could
say a blanket preemptive pardon is not OK.
Whether it ever gets to the Supreme Court
is a question.
And, you know, with with the Supreme Court,
we have right now, I'm not sure this Supreme
Court is going to rule against blanket preemptive
pardons from Donald Trump.
So that's one part of this.
Now, as far as Donald Trump is concerned,
he just pardoned his convicted former national
security adviser, Michael Flynn, last week.
He previously commuted the sentence of Roger
Stone.
He also.
And less well-known people now, just a funny
side note, things are so crazy right now that
when I read the original headline about this
story, I thought maybe Rudy and Trump talked
about Trump pardoning Trump.
The first headline I saw said something like,
Giuliani discussed a preemptive pardon with
Trump.
That could mean Giuliani talked to Trump about
Trump pardoning Rudy.
But it could also mean that as his lawyer,
Giuliani talked to Trump about Trump pardoning
himself and a self pardon is a completely
different story.
Unclear whether that is something Donald Trump
could do.
So the long and short of it is Rudy wants
immunity for everything, no matter what, in
perpetuity and a sort of free pass.
And that would be four things.
What let me see how I can say this the right
way.
The the pardon can't be for things that you
do after the pardon.
So in other words, if Rudy is pardoned and
the next day commits a federal crime, the
legal consensus is that would not be covered
by a presidential pardon.
We're going to follow it.
Many pardons coming from Donald Trump in the
next seven weeks
for sure.